どうしてもキャラが食べたい後輩っていう設定
にょぷ主アクション
me
もも行っていいですかんあぁ作ホット鈴ノクスをかけしてな
kayo さんピザ食べちゃいますね
ピザ食べたいピザ食べたいす
まじかーいやマジでピザ食っています
この腹減ってんだよなぁ
さあデリバリー頼むかなりましょう
はいというわけで今回はピザじゃあねこっと思いあの
ただピザを頼んでもあれだから何かしらなアートをかけたいわけだ
サッカーたの時に何かさんあどうか振りたいからピザを頼む上で何がプラスな要素あれ
が時間頼んでていいじゃん今度は自分たちに後は化します結構体があっ
持ってるなんて米旬に電気マッサージ器をつけたのはピザを受け取っていきますテレビ
で今から後輩がどうしてもピザが食べてっていうので膝を注文するんですけども
受け取るときについでにままずさあでもしたかい
伊澤たのか理由で mc と食べれる c アダム癒すよ
ああああああああ
また違う出ればいいみたいなってください
[音楽]
ブーブーマッサージ厳しくしようよそれ
完全一致
いざ受けているときに仲間3 c ながら空と態度悪いと思われるからマッサージて
ないような予想を4して自然と受け取るかそれがピザの提案するべきだってそのバレ
ないようにやっていけると思いますよ
やっぱりマッサージ器を準備できましたん
ana
今から前場でピザ屋さんに注文するんですけどもう2問からから順に電気マッサージ器
をつけて注文していきたいとおもいます
[音楽]
1回入れてませんがグッジョブです
ああああああ
バッハ
ああああああああ
ああ
体中に電気マッサージ器がついたので外のセットですねこんな設置人って押せばもう僕
はあなた中でマツダに起きるという試しにすっという
あっはぁはぁはぁはぁううううううっ
街づくりすごいだろ
これいけるんですか持ったのしかないこれはじゃあさっそくピザ屋さんに電話します
まあそうするとピザ勁文祭んですけど
はいのです
me
ぞデリバリーです
ヘえっと一応二人なんで2人で食べるなあ
会津だことを作りますクアトロフォルマッジの m を一つで
はいよろしくお願いします
はい
やっぱりまずミルフィーユいい
はい台に何
はい
はいよろしく宜しくお願いしますん
onnano
いっぱいになりましたねはい
はいよろしくお願いはいお願いします
これやばいでしょこれでます脚見て
ではディザーカットドックの街もさーん
普通に毎回ドミノピザの動画を撮った後ための p どの婚式アカウントからお
買い上げありがとうございましたというメッセージをいただいておりますいつも婚約し
てください以上ぞ
[音楽]
あった
言わせませんこんなっ
あっついはしごで出ませんだけど
はぁ
[音楽]
たんですけど
奇跡楽しいですはい
car
goo
[音楽]
me
dea
ルールっ